House Speaker Paul Ryan is standing by
the House Intelligence Committee
chairman we spoke with Ryan yesterday in
the speaker's ceremonial office in
Washington and asked him what he knew
about Nunez his unnamed source and the
other evidence he's seen now this is his
first extended interview since the
failed effort to replace Obamacare we
also asked about the next step for the
Republican health care bill Ryan
insisted his party isn't giving up let
me first ask you about chairman Nunez
the head of the House Intelligence
Committee you were among the first that
he briefed what did he tell you he had
told me that like a whistleblower type
person had given him some information
that was new that that spoke to the last
administration and part of this
investigation
it briefed me about it didn't know the
content of it only knew the nature of it
and that he was going to brief others
did you ask to see the documents or so
he didn't have the documents so I didn't
did you encourage him to then go tell
the president about it I know but I told
him that just added to his investigation
so you and no time said whatever you
find out you should probably go tell
President Trump about oh he was gonna
brief everybody he already knew he was
gonna go in brief so the what chairman
noonas said is he just came into
possession of new information that he
thought was valuable to this
investigation and that he was going to
go and inform people about it but he
hasn't I mean he hasn't even informed
the Republicans meeting the actual
documents I don't know that he's been in
possession of them yet let me say this
it's very important that we allow and
encourage whistleblowers to talk to
Congress can you just help me understand
this though because if it's a
whistleblower why wouldn't that
information then be shared with the
Democrats on the committee and even the
other Republicans who haven't seen it I
don't know the answer that question you
have to ask that person I don't even
know who this is
I mean you're a member of the gang of
eight you can see the most classified
intelligence that our government has
right you could request this information
yeah we want this information to be
provided to Congress and we're waiting
for it to be provided to Congress do you
know if President Trump
is under investigation himself for ties
to rest I have no knowledge of that
I do not believe that that's the case so
if we don't know that well do you think
I don't yeah I want to speak for the FBI
but I've never seen any suggestion or
any evidence that that's the case so
here's my question if we don't know if
President Trump is under investigation
why would it then be appropriate for a
member of animation to say I need to
then go brief the president yeah but I
don't believe that he is so I don't
think that he is under investigation no
one suggested that he is and and not
even in a vague way I don't believe that
he is let's talk about health care
you promised to repeal Obama care for
seven years your bill didn't survive
three weeks what happened well it hasn't
survived yet what happened is we are
going through what I would call a very
painful a growing pain I'd like to see
the growth at the end of that pain which
is we've been an opposition party for
ten years and I've been long saying if
we're going to be successful deliver for
the American people improve people's
lives we've got to become a proposition
governing party about 90% of our members
are for this bill we're going to give up
after seven years of dealing with this
after running on a plan all of last year
translating that plan into legislation
which is what this is okay so what's the
plan B well Plan B is is we keep talking
to each other and figure out how we get
to yes and how we get this bill passed
so you're not changing the policy you're
just putting more pressure know we're
listening to people if we can make
improvements to this bill all the better
so if improvements can be made of this
legislation that get people to yes
that's great the president said that
maybe he wishes he didn't do health care
first now do you regret that two things
we could not have done tax reform first
for a whole host of reasons whether a
tax reform gets one trillion dollars
easier if we do health care first like
if you want me to explain no I
understand it okay and then but the
other problem is we literally didn't
have the time to write a tax bill yet
the house is the only one with a plan
right now the White House is still
working on a plan the Senate doesn't
have a plan so it is inconceivable that
we would have been able to write a tax
reform bill and
the law before summer and we're gonna
have more of this interview an 8 o'clock
hour asking if it's still inconceivable
does the timeline still hold because
they need the trillion dollars in taxes
revenue from Obamacare in order to make
tax reform revenue neutral it's still a
key point we've got to have the money
from reforming health care to pay for
immigration I mean the paper in tax
reform yeah for tax reform tax reform do
they plan to work with Democrats to get
it done well I ask us as you know
President Trump has said let's work with
the Democrats I asked Paul Ryan that he
said I worry we're gonna push the
President to working with Democrats he
says he doesn't want to work with Nancy
Pelosi he wants to get his own
conference in line to vote for Obamacare
John Boehner would say good luck on that
yeah a lot of people would say good luck
oh yeah so we have a lot more about his
relationship with President Trump also
what he gave up for lent an interesting
story about that that's all coming up in
the next in the next hour working
forward to our 16